we make way for the great Michael Wilbon
pardon the interruption and of course
covers the NBA for ESPN and ABC Michael
how are you I'm getting slowly back I'm
not gonna say normal day I'm not there
yet but this sort of is still in a fog
if you will over Sunday's tragedy and
you know like a lot of people it's
interesting I yeah I got here Saturday
night and obviously the only reason I'm
here is of a Super Bowl you know the
week doing the telecast the I'll
broadcast from here
I haven't uttered one word about haven't
thought about it I was just listening to
you talk about I have no interest in it
I have no stomach for it I'm sure that
you know as Tuesday turns into Wednesday
turns into Thursday
I guess I'll inch my way there but you
know there's there's where are you right
now by the way you see back in the
studio I am on Lincoln and we're about a
mile from the beach okay yeah yeah down
the street yeah and maybe you have been
able to sort of successfully make that
turn I have not yet and I just I don't
know what is gonna get there but I just
I just don't care about it right now I
just have no stomach I I needed you know
yesterday was tough but yesterday was
necessary and then I I watched the 60
point game last night the re-air on ESPN
and I kind of just turned the corner and
I just said okay now we celebrate if
somebody brings up Kobe great if not we
can talk football we can talk about a
variety of things but I I had to move on
with it Mike because I I didn't want to
do the show yesterday I just didn't and
I just felt better today
I felt better today yeah haven't gotten
there yet like I said I know that you
know into my way back there but I'm part
of it is not not actively or consciously
trying to take the temperature out of
the room but other people still being
down and and that extending to me and I
might be I might have been down on my
own
I'll see baby baby this morning you know
I'll turn a corner but I suspect it'll
take another I suspect they'll take
another day or two but that's why I
wanted to have you on and because you
knew Coby
I admired Coby I didn't cover Coby but
you know there were radio interviews
that we had and I called him
conversations because he was the most
curious athlete I've ever been around
but to let people know I mean why is
this global morning taking you know
taking it it's not even you know one day
or it'll be more than one week and when
the Lakers get around to celebrating him
can you put into words why this is you
know so impactful there's so many people
you know it's interesting you say was
the most curious guy I started thinking
about okay what our conversations about
whether it was you know late after
everybody else had left the locker room
and I'm sure when you was there in Los
Angeles some of those times you were the
last guy in there with Kobe and I don't
know about you although I suspect the
conversations weren't all that often
about basketball I mean they might be
tangentially you know it wasn't about a
game that night or performance that I
said my god I'd love the performances I
love being courtside for that stuff but
the conversations worried about that and
I think people picked up on that I think
there was something and we do is we're
trying to figure out what - something
isn't and people who never meant about
that people say to me I feel like I lost
a family member and I never met him
never met him never met him at all and I
think that he was so telegenic that's
part of it and he rose above what people
expected of a guy who who went straight
to the to the professional sports out of
high school and they would still forget
about college there was an intellect
there that didn't need that and didn't
need to be fed by that and they
connected with it I was in China this
summer and the adoration Dan was
unbelievably retired for four years
and the adoration in China was was crazy
and I got I've gotten texts from
journalists in China who had made the
trip to LA over the years and Kobe was
taking Mandarin and I did with things
that just appealed to people about him
and obviously he you know sitting there
with his daughter and playing site and
you could see them at these games I just
it's all there just so many pieces that
went into this yes it's a global appeal
and I don't know that any of us saw
entirely this kind of outpouring coming
yeah and also I could hear it in Jerry
West voice yesterday I mean he was just
so torn up and and you know Reggie
Miller came on and reg said look I I
helped raised him we worked out you know
he stole my step-back jumper you know it
was we had great battles there but I I
said aside from the curiosity that Kobe
had that I always admired and he gave
great thought to your questions and you
know he wanted to be he was competitive
even in an interview he wanted to be
great but he wanted you to be great to
bring that out in him and I always
appreciated that but the one thing he
did he never shied away from the Michael
Jordan comparison he went after it he
said hey you're not nobody's giving me
the baton
I want the baton and we realized he
wasn't ready for it and then when he was
Kobe had already taken it and then he
was trying to fine-tune his game to say
I can be better than this guy and member
Tracy McGrady and Grant Hill and some of
these other guys they were like no no no
Vince Carter no we don't want that
comparison Cole he's like yes what what
what a what a compliment what and you
know then I viewed it as gutsy it's like
you bring it on and then we're gonna
watch you so closely every single night
in every big moment when you play for a
championship well then you know I think
I mentioned this yesterday I never
talked about it publicly the industry
just want me to but after you know some
huge games and playoff games
seriously though those two and I was
standing outside a locker room versus
many adieu before we before we go in and
talk to people
Toby if he was walking in off I mean
this happened in more than a dozen times
in in his career he would bump me elbow
me and say it to my ear so only he could
only I could hear it he would say
something like how would you boys does
it right Michael any was nothing but it
was though beyond good in nature it was
adoring and he just he thought he was
getting a trip for us because I said to
a limit they talked about this publicly
enough don't don't do that you know I'm
you know I'm gonna get ripped no you're
not who cares you don't carry because no
I do but people's gonna take it the
wrong way and he's probably right but
yes that was a sign of exactly what
you're talking about he he loved it and
it was it was the ultimate way for him
to comment you talk about he wanted to
be great he he got on me and he got on
Stephen hey about not writing anymore
because because Kobe knew us as sports
writers before either one of us was on
television we already knew him he knew
us and I mean he jacked me up about not
writing anymore because it was something
there was some issue or thing he said
you know once upon a time when you
weren't a TV star you didn't written a
cop
and I'm like where's this going is good
no because no I got to get on you you
you you long to do this thing you study
to do this thing and now you don't do it
what is what's deal with that and you
know that he would use what you're
describing to me is what they think he
challenged you you know sort of to be
great at what you did yeah and it was so
refreshing and I never got the feeling
and then it was by God you know people
get offended by a lot of stuff day and
they get offended by anything easily I
never I was never offended if somebody
said to me the day well he was I could
be off-putting and I'm like okay I guess
but that didn't put me off I just
thought they was engaging and so you
though I can fill you and I felt
similarly if not identically about those
things talking to Michael Wilbon yeah
the other thing is Jordan didn't have
anybody to concur after a while
Kobe always had Michael they're not
physically but even larger the myth of
you know the legend you know and then
LeBron came in but Kobe was still
focused on Michael and you know do you
had other guys retire and then he's
still chasing Michael and I think he
chased him till the very end he probably
wanted to know what Jordan scored in his
final game he scored when you think
about it right you know he'd do the
numbers but sometimes you know if I
wrote something and particularly and you
know and if I wrote something and he it
having it in front of him or somebody
sitting or people had clips then you
ever in the old days and Kobe was you
know he's 31 and nothing old about him
but remember one player shoots the PR
people used to give them clips and
they'd be at their locker and they'd
have stuff the guys who were interested
yeah I remember that and the last of
those guys what he would see something
he would know if he asked who's gonna
get on he was gonna come back at you
about a stack or a trend or something
that he had done he would say you dumb
give me shock so-and-so took last year
average per game and you know probably
the first couple times I made the
mistake of thinking that he was gonna be
in the ballpark in the ballpark you do
exactly he knew exactly what the number
was he looked it up Latinos before he
engaged in that conversation and the air
the Jordan the Jordan he never shied
away from it he loved it and you know
what else
here's the thing Michael loved it I
never get the feeling that I know that
Michael is tired of annoyed with the
LeBron both questions issues we've
talked about it a little bit publicly
more privately I never got the feeling
and maybe this week just everything was
younger and it was more tolerated and
Michael and he loved him he adored Kobe
right back he wasn't
put off by any of that and so yeah it's
just everything about the way people
engaged with him right through this was
different than we engaged to be to me
maybe you can come up with somebody else
with anybody else and it sort of sports
public life and then ain't no there was
a period we got all of it was good
people I think Michael saw himself and
how could you not like seeing yourself
in somebody else you know he liked that
he was just fearless you know Michael
doesn't see himself in LeBron he sees
that he saw himself Kobe oh no question
hey laugh a little bit celebrate a
little bit I'm gonna have to do this you
knew so I can tell from what you told me
you you made a conscious effort and you
just said I can't be shrouded in this
sadness another day and I applaud you
for it because the you know yeah you
know cuz you can't
did she just you can sit there forever
well I don't know if I'm gonna be able
to turn it today and laugh today I'd
like to I'd like for something to happen
you know what I do Mike you know push me
I'd write action I'd write a column for
Kobe well I've been asked to do it I've
been asked to do it and I didn't know
that exercise was gonna be yeah I used
to be able to write a column in a couple
of hours and now it's gonna take me six
and it's like that's gonna be six to
eight hours which is more sadness but
maybe I will be celebrated and you know
what Mike I watch that game that last
night I watched that game and I it just
lifted a little bit of this sadness it
was just that's right this is this is
what he would want you to remember that
he was you know he found a great comfort
zone with his family with his daughters
with his wife the fact that seventeen
seconds left you know he's trying to get
760 points he's pushing off Gordon
Hayward he's fighting for every little
inch every little opening I got a score
60 I'm getting 60 we're gonna win this
game and I said I I'm not grieving
anymore I'm not I'm not sad I'm you know
I'm disappointed that we lost him but
this is who he was this is what he wants
us to remember remember me as a great
father
love my daughter's love my wife and I
was an entrepreneur and I gave you a
hell of a show every bleep in time I got
on the floor he gave a show it was a
performance it's like performance
theater and that was like Jordan - there
was no talk of load management he gave
it to you every time there's full value
of your ticket times a hundred you watch
it watch last night I missed the
opportunity Dan and maybe I'll find a
way to do it anyway
thank you buddy I appreciate you joining
us Mike that's Michael Wilbon ESPN's
pardon the interruption co-host for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on be our live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]